in a clear sign of how much the war on
Gaza is overshadowing the fight in
Ukraine on the day US President Joe
Biden was to meet with Ukrainian
president vomir zalinski the biggest
news came before the meeting from
remarks Biden made off camera at a
fundraiser criticizing the Israeli War
cabinet saying some don't just not want
a two-state solution they don't want
anything to do with the Palestinians and
in his most critical comments yet he
said quote it has most of the world
support in it but they're starting to
lose that support by the indiscriminate
bombing that takes place but later when
on camera given a chance to repeat his
criticisms he didn't I think that uh we
have made it clear to the Israelis and
they're aware that the independ the the
safety of innocent Palestinians is still
of great concern and so the action
they're taking must be consistent with
attempting to do everything possible to
prevent innocent Palestinian civilians
from being being hurt murdered killed
and in his earlier off camera remarks
the president had a lot to say about
Hamas as well repeatedly calling them
animals he said they're brutal ugly
inhumane people and they have to be
eliminated clearly sending the message
that when it comes to what Israel's
stated end goal is they have the
president's full support Patty khane Al
jaaz at the White
House make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz